a show of confidence in ukraine's
capital as the canadian embassy gets
ready to reopen prime minister justin
trudeau along with his second in command
christian friedland and foreign affairs
minister melanie jolie did the honors of
raising the flag nearly three months
after the embassy shut down
thank you for staying
the moment was overwhelming for sergey
mayer who worked security at the embassy
for the last five years and remained on
duty every day
a similar sense of duty has been
motivating ukrainians to defend their
country with a fierceness that has taken
many off guard
while touring around erpine just outside
of the capitol trudeau commented on the
resilience of ukrainians the visit was
under heavy guard and kept secret
specifically what did you see that you
haven't seen over the last 70 odd days
that stuck with you
i saw just how
much
ukrainians can do standing against
a force
eight times as large as they were
in defending
their homes defending
their land
of pushing back against the russian
illegal invasion trudeau came with more
than just supportive words announcing
the removal of tariffs on all ukrainian
imports for one year 25 million dollars
for food security money for demining
programs plus more drone cameras
satellite imaging small arms and
munitions plus
more sanctions on russia
canada will support ukraine as you seek
justice for your people who russia is
killing and brutalizing
with his country still engaged in a
bloody and horrific war ukraine's
president says he still needs specific
defensive weapons to ensure his
country's freedom but says like
lithuania latvia and estonia canada has
answered his calls and he counts the
country among a small group we cannot
ask from them anymore
so
today
we are hosting the leader
of the fourth country that we also
cannot ask for more ukraine's president
says he will be putting pressure on
other nations for more help and hopes
that canada will encourage others to
step up crystal gamansen global news
keith